[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'occasion des journées nationales
architecture donc on a une visite ce
matin sur l'école polytechnique et cet
après midi sur la carte du boulon
c'était l'occasion de faire une grande
visite de la zac à la fois dans le
belvédère dans le quartier d'habitation
et en traversant sur le sur le deck
il y avait à la fois des familles avec
des enfants il ya plus de 90 personnes
des personnes qui habitent la vallée où
qu'ils habitent ces plateaux qui sont
intéressés qu'ils viennent s'installer
sur le plateau ou qui sont déjà
donc ça a permis d'aller voir les
différents projets immobiliers notamment
ceux qui sont en construction et qui
sont assez structurant pour la zac de
voir les projets qui ont déjà été
réalisés il ya deux trois ans et compte
déjà une vie déjà dans le projet comme
lee smolin ce bâtiment du belvédère et
de finir par le quartier d'habitation
qui lui en cours de livraison avec tous
les espaces 8 qui sont en excès aurait
chaussée tous les commerces et de voir
un peu la vie qui commence à s'implanter
sur le quartier et notamment le on doit
les premiers le chemin avec les
premières familles qui étaient au balcon
ce week end a donc c'était assez
agréable de se balader avec tout le
monde et tout le monde a pris conscience
aussi de l'évolution du quartier là on
en est actuellement
je pense que ces journées sont
extrêmement importants puisqu'on en fait
elles permettent de mesurer finalement à
la fois l'évolution du projet taille
saclay et de regarder son évolution dans
le temps et je pense est extrêmement
important aussi pour à la fois pour
l'ensemble du territoire c'est beaucoup
d'habitants finalement les gens du
territoire
et puis aussi pour qui le sort de
l'appropriation en fait de ce projet
c'est absolument essentiel donc cette
ouverture est très très importante pour
que y ait une sorte de me porter à
connaissance publique de ce qu'on est en
train de fabriquer aujourd'hui sur le
quartier du blosne
nous on a développé beaucoup à la fois
de deux aspects c'est à dire la question
du rapport au territoire qui existent
tout autour des gens qui habitent les
gens qui travaillent déjà depuis
plusieurs siècles
et puis ce nouveau quartier ses nouveaux
quartiers et donc quel rapport
entretient entre les deux et comment
finalement les espaces publics peuvent
fabriquer
finalement ce lien entre ces différents
quartiers à la fois nouveau et l'ancien
pour former qu'un seul et même
territoire c'est ça la vraie question d
un territoire surtout qu'ils soient ici
qu'ils soient situés sur ce département
sur l'yvette sur les communes autour de
l'yvette et fassent partie intégrante de
ce territoire
[Musique]